on y va premier binôme c'est donc jean
michel lemaire contre eux géraldine ou
là jean michel lemaire géraldine alors
attention attention vous devez trouver à
lapins dorés venez l'amener là non mais
à mon top non mais eksi d'allô prof fait
une tête de cul non mais ne riez pas une
course
faut juste cherché à la vendre mais qui
croule lapins dorés prend le salaire de
l'autre attention c'est parti
top asie go déjà lors à la pâte dorée et
qui est qu on n a pas vu mais maitient
des trucs partout jean michel c'est
gagner mojo bravo il offre à gérald
[Musique]
vallet pas que vous allez vous mettre en
place à les états castaldi allez-y
faites le à libération c'est dur à faire
allez on finira par isabelle déjà qu'ils
fassent attention
trois deux un top photo à la penderie à
lapins dorés tensions dans son hôtel
chic chuchote à la presse que talla parc
qui moi oui j'ai comme d'ajoie rien
et elle nous a pas fait la balade dans
la marre de ces bâtons mais c'est quoi
ce délire fait qu elle limitera lizzy a
été retrouvé à la fin dont le premier
qui trouve le lapin doré repart avec le
salaire de l'autre à ça ça m'intéresse
bah oui surtout castaldi est mis en
marche mais ça chauffe là bas où elle en
plateau on va vous de juillet à la main
par là et ça me va très bien
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine celui qui troublent lapins
dorés gagne le salaire de l'autre
allez-y non non non non l'avant et y est
roi
c'est vrai quoi froisser fera quoi non
non non c'est froid non jean-luc reste
plutôt à gauche mais ces deux malades
allez-y vite vite vite vite moati
seconde à nantes et froid la six fois
c'est ya plein de chocolat
mais non les mecs alors je me casse pas
le dossier ça va décoller arrêts
on se dit mais qu'est ce qu'elle fait et
georges et on y va or go away la nuit
c'est direct 1
[Musique]
[Rires]
et c'est vous les mêmes tâches à rigoler
la foule elle a voulu me casser la
gueule